[S01] 想象一下这样一个场景，呃，你刚刚在网上看中了一台价值5000 美元的高配笔记本电脑
[S02] 哇，5000 美元，这可不是小数目
[S01] 对，所以你非常激动地点了购买，然后你眼睁睁看着这5000 美元从你的银行账户里被扣除了，但就是在这同一毫秒，商家数据中心外面有一台挖掘机直接把主电源线给铲断了。
[S02] 唉，经典的挖掘机事故
[S01] 没错，砰的一声，一切陷入黑暗，商家那边根本就没来得及把你的订单记录下来。那你的5000 美元就这么凭空消失了吗？如果你最后毫发无损的拿回来了钱，那你真的得好好感谢计算机科学里的一个核心概念，也就是事务。欢迎正在收听的你，加入我们今天的这场深度探索。
[S02] 是的，是一个极其迷人的领域。
[S01] 绝对的。今天我们要潜入现实世界中那些充满混乱的数据系统，而且我们会以那本被无数工程师奉为圭臬的《设计数据密集型应用》，呃，也就是大家常说的 DDIAA为指导，硬核剖析它的第八章。
[S01] 我们就来看看数据库到底是如何在断电了，
[S01] 网络中断了，还有无数并发请求中像变魔术一样伪装出一种绝对完美的假象的。
[S02] 其实一旦你了解了底层这些所谓的完美是怎么被拼接起来的，你对日常使用的那些系统的信任度，或者说怀疑度吧，绝对会有一个彻底的改观。
[S01] 确实如此。提到数据库的事务，大家脑子里立刻蹦出来的第一张安全牌绝对是ACID，就是那个四个字母。好像只要数据库厂商拍着胸脯向你保证啊，我们完全支持ACID，你的数据就仿佛被放进了一个核爆地堡一样安全。
[S02] 是的，
[S02] 这是一种很普遍的安全感。
[S01] 那我们来拆解一下这个东西。在我看来，事务在本质上就像是现实生活中的一个撤销按钮，或者叫Undo 键。你上网买东西，要么钱货两清，大家都开心，要么就像什么都没发生过一样，整个过程干净利落地退回原点。
[S02] 对。
[S01] 绝不能出现那种呃钱扣了，但没发货，或者发了货却没扣钱的中间状态。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 正是这个撤销按钮啊，可以说是把应用开发者从无尽的噩梦中解救了出来。你想想，如果没有事务，每次数据库发生网络超时或者是硬盘故障，开发者就得自己写好几千行代码去一点点核对，到底哪几行数据写进去了，
[S02] 哪几行没写。
[S01] 那简直是灾难。
[S02] 这些潜在的错误。因为数据库承诺会替你兜底，但这里面最大的幻象就在于ACID这四个字母在今天的业界很大程度上呃已经沦为了一个营销术语。
[S01] 哇，那我们就把这层营销的滤镜给直接撕开。先看ACID 里面的A,也就是原子性这个词儿听起来像是什么不可分割的量子物理学概念，但实际上它保证的难道不就是我们刚刚说的遇到挖掘机断电时能安全撤销的那种能力吗？
[S02] 精确地说，在事务的语境里，原子性的核心就是可中止性。就是说如果一个事务包含了十个写入操作，
[S02] 执行到第五个的时候，
[S02] 系统坑了原子性，保证了数据会把前面已经写入的那五个半成品全部丢弃。
[S01] 也就是不留任何痕迹。
[S02] 没错，这就给了你一个非常强大的能力，你可以放心的重试。你不需要担心重试会导致数据被重复写入，因为失败的事物已经被彻底抹除了。
[S01] 明白，A算是给我们提供了一张干净的底牌。那我们接着看ACID里的C一致性。说到这个，这里我有一个很大的疑问。
[S02] 嗯，你说。
[S01] 一致性通常指的是数据必须处于某种良好状态，对吧？比如说账户余额不能是负数，但是等一下，如果我作为一个程序员，我写了一段极其糟糕的代码，我硬是把两笔根本对不上账的坏数据塞给数据库，难道数据库能聪明到把我拦下来吗？
[S02] 嗯，它当然不能。
[S01] 如果它拦不住，那也就是说ACID 里面的这个C其实根本不是数据库自带的功能，而是开发者自己得背的锅。
[S02] 太真实了，确实是这样。数据库确实会提供一些基础的工具，比如外件约束啊或者唯一性约束。但就像你说的那些复杂的业务一致性逻辑，比如两个账户转账前后的总余额必须绝对相等，数据库是无法自动理解的。
[S01] 它只负责干活儿。
[S02] 对，它只负责忠实的执行你发出的写入指令。所以一致性本质上是应用程序的责任，它是你通过写出正确的代码而来的结果，
[S02] 而不像原子性那样是数据库天生自带的属性。当年把C硬塞进ACID里，
[S02] 其实更多是为了凑齐这个好记的缩写。
[S01] 这简直是把包装纸扯得稀碎啊。那D呢？持久性，它承诺提交之后，数据永远不会丢，这也是个神话吗？
[S02] 啊，呃完美的持久性是不存在的。说句极端的，如果地球毁灭了，你的数据肯定也没了。
[S01] 哈哈，这倒是。
[S02] 但即使在现实层面，持久性也是千疮百孔的。比如突然断电的时候，你以为调用了强制落盘的FSINC指令，数据就安全了。但其实很多固态硬盘为了让跑分看起来更漂亮，会在内部悄悄把数据先放在仪式性的内存环存里，根本就没有真正写进闪存芯片。
[S01] 天呐，
[S01] 那一旦断电，这些本以为持久化的数据不就灰飞烟灭了吗？
[S02] 就是这样，甚至像Postql这样的顶级关系型数据库，也曾在长达二十年的时间里，在某些特定的错误处理中错误地使用了FSINC.所以对任何理论上的所谓持久保证，你都必须持一种非常健康的怀疑态度。
[S01] 看来我们以为的安全网真的是到处都是破洞。那么真正决定事物能不能抗住现实压力的，其实是那个最让人头疼的字母，也就是I隔离性。
[S02] 没错，隔离性是重头戏。
[S01] 理论上，如果我们让所有的事物排着队，一个接一个的串行执行，那绝对安全。但大家都知道，如果你在双十一的时候，让全国千万买家排成单行买单，
[S01] 系统直接就瘫痪了。所以数据必须得并发，这就迫使我们进入了一个到处都是妥协的弱隔离级别地带。
[S02] 完全正确。因为极端的安全就意味着极端的缓慢。数据为了性能允许一定程度的并发，但这也就打开了并发异常的潘多拉魔盒。比如最基础的读已提交隔离级别，它就是通过行级锁来防止两个事物同时修改同一行数据，也就是防止脏写。
[S01] 让我们把这个具体化一下。想象一下正在收听节目的你，还有你的朋友BRISE,你们两个人同时在一个二手车网站上点击购买同一辆仅存的保时捷。
[S02] 这竞争很激烈啊。
[S01] 对，如果没有防止脏写的机制，可能会发生极其荒谬的事情。
[S01] 网站可能会把车主登记成了BRISE,但最后却把付款发票开给了你。这不仅是乱套，甚至可能引发法律纠纷。所以行级所能防止这种同时写入的冲突，但是它依然防不住读取时候的陷阱，对吧？
[S02] 是的，读已提交解决不了不可重复读的问题。
[S01] 对，我们可以拿银行账户来举个例子，这绝对是一个完美的灾难现场。假设你有一千美元，分别放在账户A和账户B里各五百美元。现在你打开网页查看总余额，就在同时，后台有一个定时任务，正在把十美元从账户A转到账户B.
[S02] 嗯，很常见的场景。
[S01] 如果你的运气极差，你可能先查了账户A,看到了转账前的五百美元。就在这一瞬间，后台转账完成了，账户B变成了六百美元，而账户A变成了四百美元。紧接着你的网页去查了账户B,读到了转账后的六百美元，五百加六百对你来说，总余额变成了一千一百美元。
[S02] 凭空多出了一千美元。
[S01] 对，这太魔幻了。对于普通用户来说，
[S01] 可能刷新一下网页，数据就恢复正常了。这看起来似乎无伤大雅。
[S02] 确实网页看错一次可能没什么。但如果你是在做跨越几个小时的数据捆量备份，或者是月末的财务审计报表呢？在这几个小时里，数据库里无时无刻在发生转账。如果你带着这种不可重复读的偏差去备份，你的备份数据里就会充满这些凭空消失或者多出来的幽灵资金。
[S01] 哇，那一旦你需要用这个备份来恢复系统，这些原本只是网页上短暂显示的错误，就会变成永久性的灾难了。
[S02] 完全正确。为了解决这个问题，数据库引入了快照隔离。
[S01] 这里才真长有趣。你可以这么想象，
[S01] 快照隔离就像是给数据库拍一张巨大的全景照片。如果你在环形拍摄的时候，有人在镜头前走动，照片洗出来就会出现半个人的残影，非常惊悚。
[S02] 哈哈，这个比喻很生动。
[S01] 而快照隔离就是让整个世界在拍摄案下的那一瞬间完全冻结。不管别人之后在背景里怎么走动，怎么转账，你手里的相机拍到的始终是那个特定时间点被冻结的完美历史画面。
[S02] 这里非常吸引人的是，数据库并没有真的去冻结或者锁死整个系统。如果那样的话，性能一样会崩溃。
[S02] 它使用的是MVCC,也就是多版本并发控制。
[S02] 它的核心原则是一句非常优美的话，读不阻塞写，
[S02] 写不阻塞读。
[S01] 读不阻塞写，这听起来简直就是黑科技啊，它到底是怎么在后台瞒天过海的？
[S02] 它是通过得每一行数据维护多个版本来实现的。
[S02] 当一个事务启动时，
[S02] 系统会给它发一个单调递增的事物ID.当你修改一行数据时，数据库并不会把旧数据直接覆盖掉，而是把旧数据标记为已删除，然后写下带有你这个事物ID的新数据。
[S01] 也就是多留了一份记录。
[S02] 对，然后当你去读取时，数据库有一套极其严密的可见性规则，它会直接忽略所有在你这个事物之后才开始的那些新事物的修改。
[S01] 等等。如果每次修改都留下一个旧版本，
[S01] 那数据库的硬盘岂不是很快就为这些历史版本给撑爆了？
[S02] 这就是一个非常关键的工程细节了。数据库后台会有一个垃圾回收进程。
[S02] 当系统发现任何有正在运行的活跃事物，还需要查看某个旧版本时，这个进程就会像清洁工一样，悄悄把这些没用的历史版本彻底清理掉，释放空间。
[S01] 所以通过多版本保留和这种聪明的可见性规则，
[S01] 我们终于有了一张完美的照片。
[S01] 听起来快照隔离已经完美解决并发了。但很遗憾，
[S01] 当多个事物都在尝试并发写入时，前方的暗礁还多着呢。
[S02] 没错，麻烦才刚开始。
[S01] 比如最典型的丢失更新，两个用户同时点击一篇文章的点赞按钮，他们都读取了当前点赞数是十，然后各自在内存里加一变成十一，再写回数据库。结果两个人点赞数字最后只涨了一个。
[S02] 呃，好在丢失更新相对容易解决。你可以使用数据库自带的原子递增操作，比如直接让字段自增，而不是先读出来再算，或者呢使用显示锁定，在查询的时候直接加上FORUPDATE语句，强迫任何试图修改同一行的另一个事务，乖乖排队。
[S01] 这种显示锁定听起来是很直观，但在一种叫写偏差的怪物面前，它就突然失灵了。
[S01] 让我们来看看资料里那个绝佳的值班医生案例。
[S02] 那个例子非常经典。
[S01] 医院系统里有一条铁律，无论何事，必须至少有一名医生值班。今天呢奥利娅和BRISE两个人都在值班，但非常不幸，他们同时发了高烧，于是两人各自点开了请假系统。
[S01] 在快照隔离下，奥利娅的事物查了一下系统，
[S01] 发现目前有二人值班，于是系统判断她请假后还剩一人，
[S01] 规则成立，批准请假。
[S02] 听起来很合理。
[S01] 对，但同一毫秒，BRISE的事物也查了一下快照，
[S01] 同样发现有二人值班，他也觉得安全系统也批准了请假，两人各自提交了事务，结果是零人值班，
[S01] 医院的铁律被打破了。
[S02] 灾难发生了。
[S01] 我就想问了，为什么数据库这么笨？它既然被设定了医生人数必须大于等于一的规则，为什么不能在最后提交那一刻自己重新检查一下条件是否成立，然后再放行呢？
[S02] 这就引出了一个重要的问题，换堵。在一个事务中，你的写入操作改变了另一个事务最初查询的前提条件。数据库之所以无法在最后一步帮你拦截，是因为它根本不知道你的应用程序脑子里在想什么。
[S01] 它不知道我的业务逻辑。
[S02] 对，它不知道你是基于什么查询条件做出的请假决定。更要命的是，为什么你刚才提议的显示锁定在这里也失效了？想象一下另一个写偏差的场景，预定会议室。
[S01] 嗯，这个大家经常遇到。
[S02] 你查询上午两点到三点有没有人预定？如果没有，你就插入一条你的预定记录。在这个场景里，你最初查询的那个空闲时间段，在数据库里根本就没有那行数据。如果数据不存在，你拿什么来加锁？
[S02] 普通的行级锁彻底成了摆设。
[S01] 简直让人头皮发麻。如果你不能给一个不存在的东西加锁，那你怎么防止别人在这个缝隙里塞进去一条新数据呢？看来弱隔离级别真的是到处都是坑，
[S01] 我们别无选择，
[S01] 必须祭出终极防御了，也就是真正的可串行化，彻底告别并发异常。通往这片净土有三条路径，
[S02] 是的，有三种主流的解法。
[S01] 第一种最暴力，也就是实际串行执行。既然并发会带来问题，那我们干脆把并发杀了，把所有数据塞进内存，让所有事物在一个单线线里排成单列纵队，一个接一个地跑，像ODDB或者RAT就是这么做的。
[S02] 这种做法在过去被认为是天方夜谭。因为你想啊，如果一个事务需要通过网络发回给应用层，
[S02] 应用层算完了再发下一个指令给数据库。
[S02] 那这个单线程就会在这个网络延迟中干等着，整个系统的吞吐量会慢得像蜗牛。
[S01] 那他们现在是怎么解决这个网络延迟的呢？
[S02] 直接打包成一段代码，一次性扔给数据库。数据库在本地的内存里一口气跑完，
[S02] 中间完全不需要和应用层进行网络往返，没有网络延迟，
[S02] 单线程处理内存数据的速度其实可以高得惊人。
[S01] 原来如此，没有中间商赚差价，但并不是所有人都喜欢写存储过程，
[S01] 挑事起来简直是噩梦。
[S01] 那我们就得看第二条路，两阶段锁定，也就是二PL.这个可是关系型数据库里的老前辈了。
[S02] 确实是元老级别的。
[S01] 如果让我来形容二PL,就像是马路上极度悲观的红绿灯，哪怕大半夜十字路口一辆车都没有，只要它是红灯，
[S01] 你就得死死踩住刹车干等着。在二PL里，不仅写会阻塞写，甚至读也会阻塞写，
[S01] 写也会阻塞读，任何一点风吹草动都要加锁。
[S02] 没错，而且不仅如此，
[S02] 针对你刚才问的那个如何给不存在的会议室加锁的问题，
[S02] 二PL发明了索引范围锁，它直接把你预定的那个时间段，在索引里的整个区间全给锁上。
[S01] 连根拔起呀。
[S02] 对，这就好比你不仅锁住了当前的车，你把前后的整条车道都封锁了，别人连插队的机会都没有。
[S01] 这听起来非常安全，但也非常笨重。
[S02] 性能就是二PL最大的死穴。这种悲观机制导致系统极其容易产生死锁。比如事物A锁了行一等行二，事物B锁了行二等行一两个死死卡住，直到数据库强行把其中一个杀掉。而且一个稍微长一点的查询事物可能会瞬间锁住一大片数据，导致后续所有的写入全部排队。
[S01] 那响应时间岂不是直接原地爆炸啊？
[S02] 对，整个数据的响应时间会在一瞬间飙升。这就是为什么几十年里大家都对完全可串行化避之不及。
[S01] 直到第三条路径的出现，
[S01] 才彻底打破了强隔离必定慢的陈旧观念，隆重登场，可串行化快照隔离，也就是SCSI.
[S02] 这是一项非常优雅的技术。
[S01] 这是一种乐观变发控制。如果二PL是极度悲观的红绿灯，
[S01] 那SCSI就像是高速公路上的交通违章像头，整条路上根本没有红绿灯，大家全部绿灯全速狂奔，读写互相完全不阻塞，但系统会在暗中默默监视。
[S02] 没错，先干活后检查。
[S01] 如果你快跑到终点准备提交事物时，
[S01] 系统后台比对后发现诶，你之前查询的那个前提条件，比如我们刚刚说的有两名医生值班，在你狂奔的途中已经对别人修改过了，这就相当于你发生了撞车咔嚓摄像头给你开张罚单，当场终止你的事物，
[S01] 让你退回去，重新跑一遍。
[S02] SSI的设计极其精妙，它底层依旧依赖MVCC快照隔离的极速性能，只在提交验证阶段做手脚。数据库通过在后台记录哪个事物，读取了哪些数据范围，
[S02] 能够非常敏锐地察觉到那些过时的读取。
[S02] 在竞争不激烈，也就是大家不怎么修改同一条数据的工作负载下，SSI的性能极佳。
[S01] 就是因为不用排队。
[S02] 对，即使有一部分事物因为冲突被强制终止重试，
[S02] 它整体的吞吐量也远远碾压悲观的TOPIO.
[S01] 所以我们终于在单节点数据库里找到了性能和安全的完美平衡点。
[S01] 那么一切都大功告成了吗？很遗憾，
[S01] 现实总是更残酷的，因为我们的数据往往太大了，一台机器根本装不下，必须分布在多台机器、多个分片，甚至跨越完全不同的系统。当你想要同时更新一个关系型数据库，并发送一条消息到消息队列时，噩梦才刚刚开始。这就是我们的最后一块拼图，
[S01] 走向分布式事务。
[S02] 是的，在单节点上，事物的成功与否取决于磁上一条日志的写入，这是个原子操作。但在分布式系统中，一部分节点可能完美执行了，而另一部分节点可能因为网络断开或者硬盘满了而失败了。
[S01] 那数据就撕裂了。
[S02] 没错，如果不能保证所有节点同进同退，你的系统就会出现一半钱扣了另一半或没发的惨况。这就逼得我们必须引入两阶段提交协议，也就是TOPIO.
[S01] TOPC里面引入了一个新角色叫协调器，还有负责干活的各个参与者。如果用现实生活来打比方，这就完全像是一场经典的西式婚礼。
[S02] 哦，这个比喻很有意思。
[S01] 在第一阶段，也就是准备阶段，牧师也就是协调器会分别问新郎和新娘，也就是参与者，你愿意吗？这时候参与者必须在自己的地盘上写好日志，确保自己哪怕立刻断电，也有能力完成这件事儿。一旦新郎或新娘说了，我愿意，他们就交出了所有的控制权，这是一条不归路，他们不能再单方面返回了。
[S02] 契约已经形成了。
[S01] 然后进入第二阶段，也就是提交阶段。如果所有人都说了，我愿意牧师就会向全场宣布，
[S01] 你们正式结为夫妻。有任何人说不，婚礼直接取消。
[S01] 那么这一切究竟意味着什么？顺着这个婚礼的比喻，
[S01] 我有一个极其尖锐的工程问题。
[S02] 你问。
[S01] 如果新娘刚刚说完，我愿意，还没等牧师宣布最终结果，
[S01] 牧师也就是那个单点的协调器，突然心脏病发作晕倒了怎么办？难道伴郎伴娘所有宾客还有新郎新娘就一直坐在那干等，谁也不能离开，直到牧师在医院里醒过来吗？
[S02] 这个反问非常致命。你描述的正是两阶段提交，尤其是很多老牌系统依赖的传统XA事物标准最深层的灾难。如果协调器溃败了，那些已经投了赞成票的参与者，就会陷入所谓的存疑状态。
[S01] 进退两难。
[S02] 为什么这在数据库里是不可接受的呢？因为在等待协调器醒来的这段时间里，参与者为了保证事物随时可以被提交，
[S02] 必须死死抱住数据上的锁，绝对不放。这意味着什么？这意味着如果牧师需要二十分钟才能醒来，那两张表上的这些数据就被彻底锁死了二十分钟。
[S01] 天呐，二十分钟的锁死。
[S02] 对，任何其他想要读取或修改这些数据的关键请求，都会被直接挂起或者报错。如果协调器的磁盘彻底受损了，那这些数据就被永久锁死了。
[S02] 唯一的解决办法是让数据库管理员冒着破坏数据一致性的风险，手动介入干预。
[S01] 锁死整个业务逻辑二十分钟，这在现代互联网应用里绝对是灾难级的事故，难道就没有更好的办法了吗？
[S02] 如果我们把这和更大的图景联系起来，
[S02] 你会发现行业确实在进化。现代的NEWSQL数据库，比如spanner或者COCOROCDB在他们内部依然使用了类似两阶段提交的机制，但他们做了一个根本性的升级，他们彻底消灭了单点牧师。
[S01] 怎么做到的？
[S02] 他们使用共识算法，比如RAFT或PAXIS对协调器和参与者都进行了高可用复制。如果主协调器挂了，共识算法会在短短几秒钟内自动选出一个新的协调器，接管日志，
[S02] 继续完成事物。这就把无休止的挂起缩短到了可以忍受的几秒钟。
[S01] 哇，这就是为什么业界越来越推崇数据库内部的高可用分布式事务，而对跨越不同系统的传统XA事物避之不及的原因。今天我们从单节点的ACD幻象一路狂奔，穿过了脏读写偏差的并发雷区，见证了可串行化隔离的三种绝技，最后又在分布式婚礼上看着牧师晕倒。
[S02] 哈，这真是一场跌宕起伏的探索。
[S01] 呵，经过这次深潜，当你下次再去设计微服务架构，或者坐在架构评审会议里，看到某个厂商标榜完美支持分布式ACD时，你绝对不会再轻易被忽悠了。你会立刻明白，任何一行看似简单的事物提交代码背后都是极其复杂的可用性、性能与一致性的惨烈权衡。
[S02] 任何技术是免费的午餐。
[S01] 没错。不过在结束今天的节目之前，我想基于我们刚才讨论的分布式困境，抛出一个可能有些颠覆性的视角，留给正在收听的你去思考。
[S02] 哦，是什么？
[S01] 我们刚才花了那么多时间去探讨如何拯救那个容易晕倒的牧师，如何构建更完美的分布式二PC事物。但是如果你想跨越多个异构系统，比如跨越支付网关和库存服务，真的必须依赖这种沉重且危险的协议吗？
[S02] 这个思路很危险，但很有启发性。
[S01] 假设我们根本不用二PC,而是在单一服务的数据库里建一个以处理事件ID的表。每次操作前查下ID,操作完把ID存进去，
[S01] 利用本地的单节点事物，把整个业务逻辑变成纯粹的幂等操作。
[S02] 也就是无论执行多少次，结果都一样。
[S01] 没错，也就是说只要带有同一个ID,哪怕网络超时重试了一百次，
[S01] 产生的结果和执行一次完全一模一样。所以当你准备规划下一个庞大系统时，也许可以问自己这样一个问题，
[S01] 我们是不是根本不该再去苦苦追求如何构建跨系统的完美事物。
[S02] 这个是一个非常深刻的反思。
[S01] 相反，
[S01] 我们是不是应该从根本上改变业务代码的设计，让系统天然拥抱这种混乱，
[S01] 允许无限次的重试。也许那个我们一直渴望在混乱世界中找寻的神奇撤销按钮，那个沉重的分布式事务，仅仅是我们为了掩盖糟糕的应用层架构设计而一直住着的一根拐杖罢了。感谢你今天与我们一同潜入数据的深海，希望这次全景探索为你带来了新的启发，期待我们在下一次的求知之旅中继续拆解这个复杂而迷人的技术世界。